Okay, thank you. Thank you very much.
Thank you very much to all of you guys
for waiting for this some technique and
tech technical issue. Right. So today I
will start this session because and I
would like to share with you what is the
main goal that I had uh for this
specific
uh for this specific master class. So
considering that we are in a connected
data conference my main goal for this
presentation is to connect in the dots
about graph neural networks. So what we
will do during this m during this
masters class is to try to create this
sort of knowledge graph that includes a
lot of concepts information related to
the graph neural networks. As you can
see in this area actually we have some
information and nodes related to the
main architectures that are connected to
the ideal graph neural networks
including for instance graph
convolutional networks, graph attention
networks and so on. Then we also have
some other interesting concepts that are
more related to the research stuff that
are called permutation invariance and
permutation equivariance. Raise your
hands if you ever heard this concept
just to let me know your background.
Okay. Fine. And you will see in the on
this part right on this side of the
graph we have some ideas related to the
applications. So we will see how we can
apply graph neural networks for node
classification in the context of
antimony laundering. You will see some
application related to link prediction
and uh the related recommendation
systems and considering the hype right
around graph rag and chat with your
graph staff. We also see an application
related to how we can use graph neural
networks to improve our chatbot right
based on the graph structure.
So let me move on and this is the
journey that we will follow for uh
building this knowledge graph about
graph neural networks. uh you will see
in this slide three main steps right the
theoretical one which uh we already
discussed and mentioned uh the layers
one which involve as we said before the
architectures related to graph neural
networks and finally we will see the
applications uh if you want to have
access right to the code that we will
present during this master class this is
the link on GitHub right uh but you will
find this link also on the website of
the connected data London conference. So
if you go to the website and to the page
of this masterass you will find uh this
link as well. Uh most of the link are
collab notebooks right. So in theory you
should be able to run it also on your
lab. So let's move on and uh I have to
confess right that we in order to
understand how graph graph neural
networks work under the hood we should
have a look also at the matrix right
this is cipher the bad guy in matrix
that shows to Neo uh actually in this
specific scene he describes the fact
that all their computers are not able to
decode matrix right so they have to see
matrix encoded just seeing numbers and
so on and we will try to make the same
effort right the same experiment I would
like to convey the main idea of graph
neural networks just to provide you uh
information about the matrices that are
around that are basically the ground of
these models that are under the hood
but you will not feel alone right we
will try to understand these matrices
step by step and uh let's start to build
our knowledge graph and obviously we
will start from graph neural networks
and in order to understand the key idea
of graph neural networks we have to
clarify uh the surrounding context right
so basically the main paradigms that
characterize machine learning
applications in the traditional one you
have the in the first two steps of this
pipeline you see the traditional feature
engineering task right so basically also
in the graph we have to define some
specific metrics in order to identify
specific information related to nodes
edges and graph um at all and the Second
part of this pipeline is characterized
by the learning algorithm that is used
for the predictive task. So once the
human being or the feature engineer
defines the main features of our data
then the learning algorithm should
extract patterns from this data and then
perform help us to perform the
prediction task that in the context of
granular network should be nassification
link prediction link regression and so
on. Um I would like just to show you
this collab but this is should not be I
mean related to the uh to the main topic
of this of this master class but just to
show you the fact to provide you an
example right of the traditional feature
information that can we extract from a
graph. This is the well-known karata
club network right in which these all
these non-sent persons and here you can
see the connections between them and
when we want to extract features in a
traditional way from graphs we can use
for instance different centrality
measures at node level to understand
what is the importance of a node within
the graph right and just to let you know
that we have a look at these two
different uh graphs right in which the
dimension of the nodes represent a
different measures centrality measure,
right? The first one represent the node
degree. So the the size of the nodes is
just related to the number of links that
are connected to this node. While this
other guy shows information related to
the vector centrality measure which is
actually the basis for creating the page
rank algorithm used by Google in order
to identify the importance of a page.
And you can see here for instance here
we have small nodes the 13 one and the
81 and here are larger because the
vector centrality takes into
consideration not only the number of
nodes that are connected to to the node
itself but also the importance of these
nodes. So considering that probably 13
and 8 are connected to 32 and 33 uh this
vers the EM vector centrality measure
associated with these nodes make them
bigger than just have a look at the
degree right just to have a clear a
broad idea of what does it mean
extracting traditional features from
graph one typical feature is related to
the measure centrality to understand the
importance of the nodes so let's move on
and let's continue with the with the
presentation. So as you can see here
right what happens in the context of
deep learning and graph representation
learning basically you have a switch
right in the intermediate blocks of this
pipeline because at this level in this
perspective the learning algorithm could
also understand which are the key
features that can be useful to perform
the predictive task right and this is an
important aspect because u we can
imagine from this from this context from
this context that potentially the
features The learn features for the node
classification could be a little bit
different for the node features
extracted from the same graph for the
link prediction. Right? Because we want
to learn features that are adapt for the
downstream task that we want to perform.
So just to convey this idea of what does
it mean learning features or the
prediction task in the context uh of
graph representation learning. So let's
move on and let's try to build uh some
other nodes within our graph neural
network knowledge graph and we will add
two uh other ingredients right which are
the message passing layer and the
message passing neural network which are
let me say the key components of a
traditional graph neural network model.
uh so the message passing layer is
basically the intermediate layer within
the network while the message passing
neural network itself represent the
model at the wall. So let's try to
understand how this guy works and let's
dive into the theory part which will be
the hardest the the next ones will be
lighter I promise but let's start from
the idea of message passing layer and to
get idea we this idea we will try to
combine three different ingredients
these blocks that describes that
describe basically uh the main steps of
a message passive layer and we will try
to understand what these guys don't do
do and then the other stuff that I want
to share but it's math stuff but I will
clarify each element of this equation
that describe uh the propagation within
a message passing layer and to help you
in the understanding I will use this
graph to show how the propagation works
within a message passing layer so let's
start with our goal the main goal is to
represent uh the features uh of the
target node in our case this the blue
node at the center of this graph and we
would like to incorporate uh within
these features at the end of the message
passing layer the features related to
its neighbors. Right? So at the end of
the day when we apply a message passing
layer we want to obtain a new
representation that compared to the
initial one this representation should
encode the representation of the
neighbors. So let's imagine a social
network, right? You are the blue node.
Your friends are your neighbors. In
order to characterize yourself, we will
not use only your features, name,
birthday, and so on, but we will also
use the features of your friends. So
that's the goal incorporating the
relational structure into the node. And
let's start to explore uh this equation
that describes this process. Obviously
the starting point as you can guess is
the initial node features of the blue
one but in this case I use the light
blue color because they are not so
expressive compared to what we expect to
to generate right and the other main
gradients as I said before is
characterized by the neighbor feature.
So in this case J represent a single
neighbor. So J belongs to N means all
the neighbors of I. So these are the
features of uh the blue one node and
the main step after we have defined this
ingredient is to encode the message. So
we have to define a sort of tool in
order to transfer the rel the
information from the neighbors to the
target node. And as you can see in the
message actually we can be flexible
right in the way in which we compose
this message because because we can
concatenate for instance my features the
features of my node and eventually the
features associated with the edge. um
this is could be uh I mean in some way
useful because when we combine all these
ingredients we can improve the
expressiveness of the message passing
layer because let's imagine this case
let's imagine that I would like to
consider this message from this orange
node to this maybe is something here
that I can use
so let's imagine this idea we want to
transfer features from here to here so
we define this message but the message
that would be transferred from this
orange node to one a friend of my friend
if we consider all these ingredients
will be different right so in this way
we can discriminate better the
informations that are passed from a node
to another um
I mean it's not mandatory right we will
see when we explore the architectures
graph convolutional networks graph
attention networks and so on that we can
just use for the sake of simplicity
the features of the neighbor nodes.
Uh and then the next step using this
site is the key idea is that we want to
parameterize
the message through a multi-layer
perception.
Actually this was my face when I read
for the first times this expression. So
I would kindly ask you if you have the
same face when you hear something like
okay we want to parameterize stuff we
remove layer proet raise your hands if
you have this this face when you hear
something like that
cool yeah great thank you for your
kindness so let's understand what does
it mean right let's understand what does
it mean parameterize something to
multilayer per se and if you in this
room you get the idea probably you will
understand anytime you read a paper
about deep learning what does this stuff
means right so probably you will
understand you will get a better idea of
what you are read reading so let's start
with this matrix right and let's imagine
that this matrix uh each row of this
matrix I promise right before about the
matrix each each row represent nodes in
a graph for instance of or a word in in
a vocabulary, right? It doesn't matter
which information does this matrix
conveys.
Well, actually not so many not so much
information because the only information
that we can see is that we have a one
element initialized in a different
position for each row in this matrix.
Right? So the only information that this
matrix conveys is okay, we we have
different objects. I don't know how much
different they are. I don't know for
instance if a node in row zero or node
in node one are more similar than the
other nodes. So we have just a
discriminative representation of my
nodes or of my words in the vocabulary.
So let's make this exercise. Let's make
let's come back to the linear algebra
that we made at the university but we
will recap how it works. So basically uh
let's make this multiplication in which
we multiply the initial non features to
this par matrix that characterize this
matrix of parameters. Right? So you
start to get the idea of parameterize
what does it mean. Let's see the result.
uh the only information that I would
like to share with you is that this
matrix have the same uh I mean the
number of columns in this matrix is the
same of the number of rows in the second
one matrix but this is smaller right
because we have just three numbers not
five like in the previous one. So let's
make this multiplication if you don't
remember how multiply matrices let's
recap this concept. So the idea is that
in order to get the top left value right
0.44
here we have to sum different products.
So we have to sum this product 0.0.55
which is zero right and the second one 0
minus051
which is zero again and zero again. Oh
now now I can put 0.44 44 for my sum.
But this is still right it remains like
this because we have to multiply again
zero or 0.64 right this is linear
algebra matrix multiplication and if we
perform the same thing right in order to
identify this value to compute this
value we make the same exercise. So
considering that this one is in the
fourth position of this matrix this 0.02
02 value will be put here because all
the other matrices the result is zero.
So maybe you can start to build your
intuition about what parameterized
through a multi-layer perception means
in the sense that the position of of the
one in the row establishes which row I
will achieve uh at the end of this
matrix. So this is an important aspect
because you can see here that in this
row I initialize the one at the fourth
position. So I get the fourth row here
and I put it here. And I make the same
exercise here. I have a one initialized
to the last position. So I get the last
row and I put it here. So it works like
a sort of matrix, right?
But what we actually got right just
making this simple matrix multiplication
is a new representation of the nodes
right because now we know that the first
row represent my first node or my first
word the second row considering this
multip multiplication represent my
second word and you can see clear
difference right between my input so the
initial features that I have the year
and the output, right? Which is Yeah,
please.
>> Yeah.
>> The matrix on the left here is
permutation matrix.
>> Uh it could be it could be seen as a
from this perspective and then we will
see a permutation matrix uh more related
to the context of graph to understand
how does it connected. As you said, we
can see this matrix from this p
perspective. In this context, I would
like just to use this matrix in order to
to say that we have a very uh low
representative
expression right for my nodes or for my
words.
>> Question, how did you come up with the
second matrix here? The one with
>> this is is initialized randomly.
Basically this is the parameter matrix
that in any deep learning algorithm is
initialized randomly and so we will see
in a while that these numbers actually
are not stable right are just
initialized as it is but they will be
updated during the training phase in
order to get the representation that we
want in the last matrix for the
predictive task. I will not focus on the
back propagation here but I will try to
convey the idea.
So I don't know if I answered your
question really. So this is the result
right? So we create this sort of mapping
and we obtain this new matrix. And what
is the difference? Well, now we do not
have just one initialized in one
position of the first matrix. But we
have a collection of numbers. And this
collection of numbers is the
representation of my new words. Sorry,
the representation of the nodes and the
words in a new vector space. And this
vector space is very relevant, right?
Because let's imagine to add a new word
or a new node into this matrix. What
should I do? Obviously, I should add a
new row because I add a new word. But
the problem is that in this
representation, I should also add a new
column, right? because I need another
space to initialize my one to make uh
this uh uh I mean discrim discriminative
representation
but this doesn't happen right with this
result because the number of the columns
will remain the same right I will just
to add a new row to represent a new word
and as we said before we have different
numbers than one so potentially we can
we are able to represent similar stuff
or very far stuff using these numbers
because these numbers will be the result
of a parametric matrix that will be
updated during the back propagation. So
you have to imagine that when we perform
a predictive task during the training
phase and you this ideas is sharable to
any deep learning algorithms these
numbers will be updated in order to
obtain a representation that is more
meaningful right because we can express
more information with this matrix we can
express for instance similarities. So
basically if node zero and node one will
be similar then this number will be
closer.
Did you get the idea? Better than before
at least just please.
>> Yeah.
>> No it's different. We will see how um a
GC matrix is different because in a GC
matrix we have a one initialized to
potentially more positions in order to
describe the graph but we will have a
look at it.
Yeah, this is just you have to imagine
that
let's consider for instance a
vocabulary, right? If you in your
vocabulary you have five words, right?
You can use just there's a
representation to say okay we have some
five different objects. So this is the
idea and it can be applicable also to
graphs and
basically I don't know if you ever heard
the word to back which is basically I
mean the archetical model the language
model I mean the first part of the
network does just this matrix
multiplication right that's the idea and
what we usually apply at the end in
order to improve the expressivity it's
not important to understand for the goal
of this M this master class but the idea
is that we will apply a nonlinear
activation function and the simplest one
is just for instance the real loop which
you put to zero all the negative values
right why we apply a linear activation
function but the idea is that we apply
it because we want to make we want to
obtain a results that we cannot obtain
just by multiplying matrices right so we
adjust the expressiveness of our
learning functions in order to learn
more complex stuff.
So I hope I mean this is the idea. This
is the neural network the traditional
neural networks and this is what does it
mean parameterize something through a
multi-layer perception please
>> uh represent the all nodes each row
represent a single note
yeah exactly
yeah exactly and just the features of
our Not the relationship one.
>> Yeah, just the features.
Yeah, exactly. And from these features,
the only idea that we get is okay, they
are different, but what we want to get
at the end of the day is how much they
are different.
Exactly.
>> Yeah. Exactly. Exactly. This is the
simplest way right to represent features
just to discriminate please.
>> Yeah.
Yeah, exactly. You have to imagine that
we have a collection of different data
points, right? So each row is a data
point. We are not making something
complex like batching or stuff like
that. Just we want to represent
something using a representation that is
discriminative in terms of how we
represent stuff.
>> Yeah. Exactly. And this collection of
pairs is represented by the entire graph
potential.
So thank you very much for all your
questions. I hope that this linear
aruary cap would be useful to recap some
key concepts. So I hope that when I will
talk about during this presentation
parameterize something through a
multi-layer perception now we get a
better idea. So we want to represent our
features in a different vector space
which is potentially more expressive
and on the other side more importantly
it's learnable right because it will be
learned for considering the predictive
task.
So let's compress this message right in
order to simplify our equation and let's
move on
and the next operation is aggregate
using a permutation invariant function
and you know my face right we already
seen before what does permutation
invariant function means you know it
raise your hands if you have already
just one so put your hands here and we
will continue with the next part but
anyway way I'll try to convey this idea
of permutation in various functions in a
in a hopefully clear way right you will
tell me later
so I have to add to convey this idea of
permutation uh invariant function of
another concept that is very close to
the graph world which is a graph
isorphism
and we will understand why so I have a
question for you are these two these two
graphs equal
Raise your hands.
One, two. Okay, we have half of the
audience that says that these graphs are
equal and al that says no. Well, it's
not really true, right? Because if we
see the labels of these nodes, right?
The first one represent a sort of path
with different phases. We have phase
one, phase two or phase three. and the
other guy looks like a sort of a
bipartite graph in which we have a node
representing a user and the other node
representing movies. Right? So the
connection could be for instance some
recommendations or some likes of Ben for
the X-Men movie and um so the graphs are
different but maybe I got what you meant
because the second next question is do
they have the same relational structure?
So I would ask to raise your ants if you
say so. More ants right now. Great. And
actually there are some very
straightforward way to understand if
these graphs have the same relational
structure. And in order to demonstrate
that we have to we just re label uh the
nodes right in order to forget what does
these labels mean. And the first
requirement is trying to perform a
onetoone mapping right. So basically we
want to identify uh from the starting
graph the G graph a node that could be
in some way mapped to another odd node
of the graph H. Right?
So basically we can do this exercise if
the two graphs have the same number of
nodes. But there is another aspect right
which is related to what the smartest
guys call um
nonadjacency or adjacency in this graph.
So what we want to preserve in this
onetoone mapping
the thing that we want to preserve is
the existing and no existing
relationships between these two graphs.
And um in order to make this exercise
right let's try to coloring the nodes
and let's let's try to focus on the
colors and what we will see is that if
we consider the colors with notice that
some adjacency are preserved because the
blue color blue color node is connected
to the orange one and to the green one
in both of the cases right uh the orange
one is connected to the blue one in both
of the cases and the orange one is not
connected to the green one in both of
the cases. So in a very straightforward
way we understood that these two graphs
have the same relational structures and
the smartest guys says that okay this is
what we have just said. So the answer is
yes these graphs are different but
actually they have the same relational
structure and this but guy says that G
is isomorphic to H. So here again this
idea is isomorphism. Two graphs are
isomorphic if beyond what they represent
in the real world they have the same
relational structure. And we
demonstrated in a hopefully
straightforward way why G is isomorphic
to H. And there exists actually a more
formal definition of isomorphism.
So let's consider these two matrices.
And actually these two matrices
represent the adjacency matrices of
these two graphs. So basically
um
um they represent in some way the
relationships that characterize a graph.
So considering that we have a
nondirected graph uh we have a symmetric
matrix along the diagonal and the first
row and the first column of this matrix
represent node zero. And the fact that
we have a one initial initialized here,
it means that a one initialized in the
first column, it means that the not zero
that is represented by the first row is
connected to node number one which is
represented by the column one in which
this one is initialized.
Okay. So that's uh how we can represent
information related to the connection
within the graph using the adjust matrix
and this is also true for the other guys
right in the sense that in this case the
first row at least I mean the the row
number one and the column number one
represent the adjacencies of one with
all the other nodes. talk these ones
represent the fact that node one has a
connections with zero and with two and
this other guy I mean
uh represent the same stuff but if we
have a look at these matrices I mean
it's not so easy to understand that they
are the same graph let's try to make
this exercise in which we hide the the
the information upstairs right I mean
the graph the the drawing of the graph
and let's consider the fact that if you
just look at this IGSC matrix this graph
do not look the same right I mean it's a
bit hard so according to the idea of
graph isomorphism we can say that G is
foromorphic to H if there exist a
permutation matrix which actually
represents the transformation that you
can see in these rows right so basically
this permutation matrix the color are
corresponding to these arrows not rows
sorry arrows uh so for instance The fact
that in the uh row zero we had a one
initialized into the second position it
means that we created the map right
between node zero and node two. So a
permutation matrix describe this
transformation and according to the math
if you are able to basically apply this
computation. So basically the adjacency
matrix of graph G it is equal to the
product of the permutation matrix um
with the adjacency symmetric of the
graph H uh and the product of these guys
with the transpose of this permutation
matrix. Transpose just means that we add
the row and we put the row in the
column. This is just the meaning of
transpose. So we should verify that this
equivalence is correct.
uh and if this equivalence is correct so
basically there exist sorry a
permutation matrix that make this
equivalence correct then these these two
graphs are isomorphic
and if you do not do not trust me
because you don't have to trust me but
you you do have to trust the code I
prepare for you a collab notebook right
in which I will see that this
equivalence using that permutation
matrix is maintained is correct I would
say so here we have a representation of
G. Here we have a representation of H.
You can see the adjacency matrices here
and you can see the permutation matrix
here that basically correspond in theory
to this one. Right?
So let me go here
and uh when we perform this
multiplication right we see that x is
the result of this multiplication and
you see that the fact that x is equal to
the adjusted imag is true right so we
tested on the code that this stuff is
true
okay cool so let's move
Why this idea of graph isomorphism is
important in connection to graph neural
networks. Well, consider the fact that
uh for instance we want to uh I have to
interrupt Stephano. Uh I have just three
minutes left for the registration.
Very quick. Okay, so I can continue to
explain.
So the basic idea, let's imagine that we
want to develop a model that is able to
learn from graph structures. Why graph
isomeorphism is important? Because one
of the requirements should be well if a
graph neural networks look at two
isomeorphic graphs the results could be
the same because otherwise
we didn't develop a model that is able
to recognize the most important aspect
of graphs which is the relational
structure. So we have to impose or our
expectation is that okay if we have a
graph networks we want to that the
output of this graph networks will be
the same when we have two isometric
class. Is it clear this this concept and
I have to say that this is true but we
see how the message passing layer and
the message passing neural network allow
us to develop a model that is able to
recognize basically graphs that are
isomorphic. So basically graphs that
have the same molecular structure and
regarding the second part of this
statement it should be true as well
right in the sense that we want that a
graph neural network should be able to
disseminate among nonisomorphic graphs.
So basically we want that a graph neural
networks when sees two different graphs
that have different relational structure
produce the different results. Right?
This is the opposite. perspective of the
perspective
I will not go through into the details
but it will not always true right so
there are some cases of graphs of
nonisomorphic graphs that will generate
the same output when we apply a graph
model and this should be a problem
because it means that the graph neural
networks make some mistakes because it
recognizes as the same thing
does as I said I don't have time to
understand
to go to through the mathematical
demonstration but just to let you know
that there are some cases and we are
able to identify the expressiveness
pressure right to understand the cases
in which graph neural networks are not
able to dissuate between nonisomorphic
graphs just to let you know um may I
continue ste or
>> yeah I was going to creating another
meeting for
Okay.
>> Okay. Let me know when
>> to clear.
>> No, hopefully it's a bit better clear
than when you start this master class
right around this this concept.
So why we talk about this permutation
idea? You understand the role of
permutation in order to identify graph
with relational structures. uh we talk
about permutation invariance because we
hear yes and then we want to apply a
computation that keep right this
permutation
uh that is robust right to this
permutation that changes and uh for
instance just to anticipate what I will
talk about later but let's consider for
instance the sum operation this is a
permutation environment because we can
change the order for instance of the
nodes we can re label the nodes but the
output mutation variance.
>> The other is permut
Okay. So we'll move closer, right? Um
because we have just explore alpha the
graph.
Okay. The idea of permutation in
variance we already understood right in
the sense that we have these two
matrices represented as the true
isomeorphic graphs and basically when we
apply a message passing in a network
what we want to obtain is the same
output of the graph.
But in order to guarantee this behavior,
the appropriation invariance aggregation
function is not enough because again we
can apply the sum to some objects but we
want to be sure that the object that we
reach before the sum already robust
right to the to the permutation. This is
what we do. uh the key idea of
permutation equivarians is that the
output of the message passing layer is
permuted in the same way of the so in
other words we don't care if we apply a
permutation and then we apply a message
passing layer we will obtain the same
thing if we just apply the message
passing layer and then apply the
permutation and this is important right
because if the output of the message
passing layer is permuted in the same
way of the input
It means that the model was able to get
this idea of permutation. So it's able
to track this permutation and
potentially explore uh potentially
support the full network at all in order
to be robust to the permutation in
invariance. So if you do not trust me
again trust the code I prepare for you a
message passing layer using Python
geometric right you can see here the the
import installation and blah blah blah
and we will use a library that is
related to the chemical components and
stuff like that and you should be able
to recognize right uh the forward
propagation here with the message
aggregate and update and basically we
have prepared also the architecture of
the message line um of the multi-layer
perception. Right? In our example, we
just have a look at the one VR layer and
then apply the redo. Here we have just
two different I mean uh multiplications
and so on. So I would like to focus your
attention actually on this um basically
unit test for getting the invariance and
the equivalence.
uh here we will see the out of this
printing and we will notice what
happens. So let's have a look at the
graph before the permutation. So here
you have the edge tensor. So this means
that you have a central node which is
zero and all the other guys one two
three four connected to this zero. This
is what is mean this edge and index
tensor. Um you have the node features.
It's not important what does that mean?
The only important thing is saying that
the input feature associated with node
zero are different from all the other
nodes. And then we apply a permutation
tensor which makes a similar which has a
similar behavior that what we have seen
during the presentation. And let's see
what changed right in terms of um in
terms of of the graph. Now before we
have these four collection of zero as
source nodes right now we have this one
which is now the central node after the
permutation type and you see this
permutation also in the features because
you you add this unique feature
representation in the position zero and
now this is in the position one. But
when we apply a multi-layer perceptual
uh sorry a message bus network what we
notice is that the output before the
permutation is actually the same that we
obtain on the permuted class. So this is
the key ideation in violence. We don't
care about the characteristics of the
layers. So basically we can have 20
layers. We can have I don't know million
of embeddings as a dimension. We don't
care the behavior of the full message
passing neural network will be always
this right like permutation inv. So we
can permute the nodes in the graph but
we will obtain always the same results
and the equivalariance is a bit complex
but maybe the next example will clarify
the idea. We permuted the graph in the
same way and this is the output that we
achieved. So basically each row
represent the updated features of my
nodes. And what you see right that here
before the permutation we has this row
right
and after the permutation we have a
different stuff in the first row. So
what happens remember that we are
talking about permutation equivalent. So
basically what we want to check is that
the output of the message passing layer
has been permuted in the same way and
actually it does because if you see that
basically we had this exchange between
node zero and node one in the
permutation you see that this row right
now is in the first position here in
position one sorry and then what I had
here
it's what I had in the first row. So the
output it's different but when we apply
a permutation to the output of the first
message passing layer what we'll notice
actually we notice that this stuff are
the same right because when we apply the
permutation to the output of the message
passing layer we obtain the same results
of the p of the message passing layer
which processed a permuted graph. Right?
This idea could be quite hard but I
hopefully that in the next examples that
actually is applied not to graphs but to
images and convolutional neural network
we clarify this idea. So we can apply
this idea of epivirus and invariance to
different objects including my cat which
is called minus I don't know if it's
easy to pronounce also for Italian guys
I would say. And this idea is that we
apply the permutation to the graphs but
in case of images we can apply another
transformation which is the shift which
is the translation. And when we
developed a convolutional neard network,
we will notice that the full
architecture of a convolutional neural
network will produce the same label for
this cat because the single convolution
neural network layer are not permutation
invariance in this case sorry
permutation equivarian but shift
equivarian.
So I hope that you got the idea in some
way because
I mean I will go quick but you can have
a look at the code in order to get the
shift equivarian for the images. I
implemented a convolutional layer from
scratch. But this idea of equariance
layer is extremely important in deep
learning architectures
because the idea is that if you want to
create a model that is very expressive
considering the input information we
have to incorporate some intermediate
layers that are equivarant to some
transformation that could be permutation
in case of graph and could be shift
translation in the case of images.
So that's the hidden stuff related to
gra to to deep learning architectures.
We usually just think that okay we just
stack layers and see the output and
whatever what happens is okay but for
some specific perspective at the
research level we have to introduce some
internal layers that are equivarial to
specific transformation of the data in
order to obtain something a model that
is able to understand what the data is
right so this is the idea of geometric
deep learning if you ever heard this
concept concept sometimes reading papers
or reading stuff written by Michael
Brownstein. He talks about geometric
deep learning and what we have seen now
is the application of this idea for
grass and the application of this idea
in the case of images.
So let's move on
and now let's focus on the layers part.
I will go quickly I will try. So uh now
we will talk about convolution graph
convolutional networks graph attention
networks and graph sage and I have to
clarify right that each if you have a
look at the python geometric
implementation each of these layer is
implemented with an abstract within an
abstract class using right this specific
methods that we have introduced before
and what is the key difference between a
graph convolutional network and a
traditional me message passing layer.
uh sorry a traditional multi-layer
perception well I mean it's different
considering the message passing layer
right but at the same time you see what
happens in the forward propagation I
just not pass only the x which is the
the matrix of the features but I also
pass an ed index that describe how these
features are connected because these
represent the structure of the graph so
let's have a look how graph
convolutional network graph attention
networks and graph sage can be um
understood in a unified framework which
is the message passing layer. This is
the equation that we have seen at the
beginning right. Uh I make some
transformation just to simplify the
notation right. So here is the message
passive layer and we can apply a special
specialization for creating a graph
convolutional network. What is the
difference between these two equation?
Actually the only difference is
character characterized by this factor
CI which is just a normalization factor
that is applied and it is computed
u using this right using this stuff. So
basically we want to obtain considering
the adjacency matrix and the degree
matrix a sort of a number to normalize
uh the messages that are passed through
uh the graphs. Right? So this is the
idea of the graph convolutional network.
We have seen that the permutation
invariant function in this case is
instantiated. Let me say using a sum
some operation. So let's let's have a
look right you can also have a look by
yourself because I I studied the collab
but I would like just to let you know
how you can implement a graph
convolutional layer from scratch using
numpy in this case. So this is the graph
that we want to represent right a
central node peripherical nodes
connected to the central node. So this
is the adjacency matrix right you have
one here and you have one here because
the zero node is connected to all the
others and what you can see here is that
also the values in the diagonal are
initialized to one. It means that the
new graph that we want to use for the
message passing propagation consider
also self loops right. So we add the one
into the diagonal. So let's start to
build what we call the normalized
adjacency matrix which is actually
represent the C value right that we have
seen before. So the first step is the
degree a vector. So this number means
five because zero is connected to the
four nodes and to itself. And this is
why here we have two because all the
nodes are connected to zero and to
themselves. And we put this vector into
the diagonal right. We perform the
square root because um yeah here one on
two it means square right. So this if
you make the square root of these values
you obtain that. So if you square this
value you should get something that is
close to five and then we apply the
inverse operation. So one to these
values and so you will obtain all this
stuff and then we apply the the full
operation that is described by this
equation with this right and we obtain
these results. What these results means
let's consider not zero right which is
the more connected one in our graph. We
want the fact that when we pass I mean
the features we want to have a small
weight let me say for the message that
is passed from zero. Why? Because you
have to think always in terms of
expression.
If I am connected to all the nodes in
the graph, it means that my features are
not so relevant to understand the
features of the others because this is
shared from all the nodes in the graph.
So why this is why it's why this is
value is low right because if I am
connected to all the graph of the nodes
well the features of my friends I mean
the my feature my features are not so
relevant to describe
to describe my friend right so this is
why this value is very low relative to
the node zero while the other values of
the other guys of zero is 0.5 right
because I mean their features to
understand the features of the neighbors
are more relevant because they have less
connection.
So the operation that we perform is try
to let me say normalize right the
contribution of each node in which you
want to make more important the
contribution of the nodes that have less
connections within the graph right so
why this is why these values are higher
than are higher than before and the next
stuff it's is not so important because
it's something that is traditional
related to the message passing framework
the only thing that I would like to show
you is that this is uh I mean the final
output after uh after the propagation
after to apply the reel. But the most
important thing to understand to the
graph convolutional network is this
normalization stuff that is used to
create a lower contribution for nodes
that are more connected within the
graph. So let's continue and let's go to
the graph sage. I will go quickly
because I will also show you some
applications that could be interesting.
So let's have a look at the difference.
Um I mean in this case we do not apply
the sum as a permutation invariant
function but we apply the mean. Actually
in the original paper of grass age you
also find some aggregation function like
LSTM
but the problem with this function is
that it's not permutation invariant
because LSTM is a recurrent neural
network stuff. So it takes into
consideration the sequence of the
information. So if you change the order
the output of the STM changes. So this
aggregation function implementing grass
sage is not permutation invar just to I
mean share with you this this high level
idea. Now what we have in terms of
differences we have in the original one
we have just one side so just a single
multi-layer perceptron for all the nodes
in the graph here you have a different
two different multi-layer perceptions.
Why? But graph sage is very helpful in
recommendation systems and considering
that in recommendation systems uh the
nodes in the graph are not connected to
the same object. Usually in Netflix I'm
not connected to the other users of that
of Netflix. I connected to the movies.
So I need the two different uh
multi-layer perception because I would
like to have a representation for the
movies and I would like to have a
representation for the juices. So this
is why in g the equation is implemented
like this. So if you take and if you try
um
uh to use Python geometric right and you
try to apply uh graph convolutional
network in a bipartite graph graph you
will notice that it will launch an
exception right because graph
convolutional network at least for its
your original implementation is not able
right to uh manage biparted graph
because it starts from a shared weight
parameters right for all the nodes in
the graph.
Um I move uh forward and the only thing
that I would like to show is the graph
attention networks. And the key idea of
the graph attention network is that we
want to add a parametric representation
not only to the nodes but also to the
edges. Right? So we want to in some way
parameterize and make the edge
representation learnable. also for
graphs that do not have at the certain
level edge representation but using a
multi-layer perception we want to
perform also this task I go I will go uh
very quickly because I don't want to get
too much time on this this is just the
step by step of what graph attention
networks does and you have the code
which encode the mark equation that you
have seen in this presentation in this
part related to graph attention network.
What does it mean this stuff? The last
step of graphation network here
basically at the beginning we will have
we we have edges that have no
representation at the end of the
graphation layer we obtain a learnable
representation for the edges. So we can
learn in this way how a node is
important or getting for instance the
representation of the other nodes.
This is just a quick uh idea right you
have the collab so you can see the
mapping between the math equation and
the implementation in numpy and uh these
are also some of the differences between
the different architectures. The main
thing to get the idea that you want you
have to bring atom is I have two diff
different architectures but I can
describe them under the same head
represented by the message passing
layer. That's the uh idea. So we talk
about um the intermediate the layers
part. So we discussed graph
convolutional networks, graph attention
networks and graph sage. Now we see a
bit of applications right maybe some of
you could be interested more in this
part so we will see in the first column
notebook how we can apply graph neural
networks for n classification in the
context of antimony laundering so uh we
get here as a starting data set the
elliptic data set I don't know if you
have heard this data set but basically
it's just photograph a picture um of the
bitcoin network right and um
we will see how we prepare the data set
for our graph neural networks. These are
the initial CSV files that we have we
have three different files features
classes and edge list. So for the
features for each node that is
identified by this code we have a
collection of features. So a collection
of numbers actually we do not we do not
know what they are because they are
anonymized right but just to let you
know that we have a collection of 167
columns that represent the features. We
have the classes
and the CSV file in this case contains
the node id and the class which could be
one true or unknown because actually
most of the graph does not have any
label and if I remember well two means
elicit or what we will see in a while
right and then you have the edges right
so basically an edge list in which you
have the source node and the target node
and that's it that's enough for a graph
neural
So let's understand the class
distribution here. Okay, unknown most of
the graph uh 77%
the elicit nodes identified by the label
two are the 20% we have just a small
portion of illicit nodes right so for
training a model we can have to just use
this part right because we cannot use
the unknown label for the training
because it's unknown and uh let's move
on right and
these are just transformation
information that are applied to the
data.
So I would like just to show you how the
result of the splitting is before the
training. So here you have the number of
training nodes that are used and the
number of validation and testing nodes.
And at the same time we would like to
see that the distribution of the edges
is the same right for the training for
the validation and for the test. And so
this is what uh what you see here. Um
the training basically cover the 90%
right of the entire graph and we have
the 10% of illicit nodes and the other
remaining part of of list nodes right um
the same thing for the validation
validation sorry 8% around for the
elicit nodes and 9.8% for the elicit
nodes in the test. So we perform the
training right and when we perform the
training we use these models right we
added another model is called gene which
is a little bit different architecture
but it's not so relevant right now and
so when we try the model on this graph
we can see right basically the time
right could be interesting interesting
information the GN this the GCN is the
uh fastest one because it has less
ingredients than the other less
parameters than the other architectures.
The graph attention networks is the
probably the slowest one because as we
said before we want to learn uh
learnable parameters not only at the
node level but also at the edge level.
So we have more parameters to learn in
the graph attention networks and then
you have graph sage and graph
isomeorphic networks. Um
you see the architecture right here uh
the node classifier is just a layer you
will find it in the code that just
produce a probability right as output of
the graph
and let's have a look at the results
okay these are all the usual stuff we
have seen from this result that
basically the graph sage seems the
better uh choice right for understanding
illicit and nonlicit
nodes within the graph. So you can see
that it works better than all the other
guys for all this metric. Precision
means if the um basically if it is able
to get all the elicit nodes and recall
if I mean it is able to get all the
illicit nodes in the in the universe.
Um, regarding the confusion matrices,
this provides also an interesting
information because it seems that uh the
sage overcomes all the others especially
in predicting and detecting illicit
nodes here you have 86%.
So basically considering also the fact
that the data set is imbalanced right we
have seen that 90% of the nodes are
defined as listenit and 10% is defined
as illicit. This is a good result
because in the 86% of the cases grass
sage you see the results right compared
to the other performs better also in
recognizing illicit nodes and from these
probability figures you see also that
sage graph sage is more uh it has less
confusion right the fact that this box
is the smallest one it means that uh SPR
age is pretty sure about his results. It
means that the probabilities are closest
to one or closest to zero distributed
are the edges. So no notification we are
able to run the training to all our
models using bio geometric and we have
just commented the results.
The next part that I would like to show
you is and you have obviously the collab
notebook that you can test by yourself.
Uh the next part is the link prediction
in the context of recommendation
systems. Uh so let's have a look.
In this case, we would like to recommend
movies to users, right? So the starting
data set is the movie lens data set. So
in this movie lens data set you can see
here you get the movie and in this case
you have some features that are more
understandable uh for understanding the
representation of the movie and then you
have just the ratings right for users
you do not have any any feature
representation so what we do is just a
pre-processing phase in which we
transform these generous generous for
for the movie in one hot
representations, right? Uh I mean
basically we initialize one if the movie
is an adventure movie and so on. So a
numerical representation from these for
these gems. Um we prepare our data. uh
so we reassign the ids because we have
to work with matrices it's not so
relevant and in this case compared to
the previous scenario uh which is
related to n classification in the case
of link prediction uh basically we have
to define the positive examples which
are represented by the links but as you
will see here we also have to define the
negative examples because uh in the
context of n classification you have
list or illicit nodes in graph that
represent recommendation you have just
positive links right you have the link
the fact that the link does not exist it
does not means that uh that the movie
could not be recommended right so what
we does right is to create a reverse
edges right um no sorry what we does
here is creating this initialize this
parameter negative sample ratio to true,
right? So for any positive link, we will
create two negative links in order to
have uh the bad classes, right? The
elicit uh scenarios like like we had in
the case of not classification.
Um
okay, so we split our data considering
this stuff. Uh so here you have the you
use this random link split for making
this uh splitting. uh you have the
percentage of val validation test, you
have the percentage of the test test,
the test set uh and you have this this
joint train ratio which is in my opinion
quite interesting. Um consider the idea
of a message pass
when we apply a message passing it means
that there is a link right between the
nodes.
So if you use a training process in
which we use all the nodes for the
message passing we cannot learn too much
information because the message passing
implies that we have a link. So we just
predict link that we already seen during
the message passing. So the idea is I
try to applies this ratio in order to
within the training set the 70% of the
nodes is used for the message passing
and the 30% of the reminding of the
training set is used to check if this
message passing worked. So here's the
idea. uh we create as we said an
aerogious graph because we have
different objects and we have a
different
um we have different objects in terms of
users and in terms of movies
um we apply a further sampling here
right so for the message passing uh for
the loss that we select for the message
passing we will not use all the
relationships but we will use just 20
relationship at the first level and 10
relationships at the second level.
Right? So basically we simplify the
message passing not considering all the
neighbors but just the neighbors the 20
neighbors of the the first layer the
first message bus layer and 10 neighbors
at the second layer.
So this is just preparation of the data
and then we can try the model right. uh
as I said before actually graph
convolutional network could not be used
in its original implementation for
leveraging bipartite graph but if you
will we have a look at the code this is
a slightly different implementation of
graph convolutional network but it works
in the same way
uh but use more um parameters different
type of parameters for the different
objects within the graph. So we trying
the uh these models they are quite
slower right than before. Um I mean the
GC GCN should be and actually in this
case Sage is the fastest ones right. uh
I would like to focus
uh I would like to focus right now on
the results because if we consider a
node classification as a binary
classification of if we consider link
prediction we actually consider the same
type of problems but in the case of link
prediction it's harder right because you
do not have just illicit or elicit nodes
but you have link to predict so the I
mean the number of links that could be
you can find in a graph it's uh it's
more than the number of nodes but in
this case right the graph sage has the
better behavior again you can see here
that it works much more better than the
other models right in uh suggesting
existing links so in suggesting good
recommendations so these numbers that
you can see here uh it means that the
model is able to suggest good movies
that can actually that I could like
right while the other guys are not so
good in this specific task. But if you
have a look at the GCN, right? The GCN
is very effective in predicting
basically movies
uh I mean to move out movies that I will
don't like. So this is why these numbers
is is so high. But if you want a
recommendation that actually recommends
good movies and sometimes makes some
mistakes, graph sage is the right choice
in this context. So it's it's
interesting because from this uh short
overview we have seen that the graph
sage model for its characteristics it's
better considering the same number of
parameters basically for not
classification and for the link
prediction task.
So I will move on right uh because what
I would like to show is a last
application that it's on the hedge right
and it is related to the chat with your
graph or graph rag stuff means
um in a traditional graph rag based
agent you have the semantic retriever
that actually makes some queries to a
vector database or you have what we call
a knowledge graph retriever which for
instance generate cipher or sparkle
queries in order to make some order in
order to perform some queries in the
graph. Right? So we have in also
advanced graphbased agents these two
components can that can interact to each
other. But we talk about graph neural
nets right and we can consider graph
neural networks not only to make the
traditional prediction not
classification link prediction but also
for improving a chat with your graph
applications.
And I would like to show you the demo of
G retriever. And just to underline how
connected data London is on the edge
this model will be presented in new new
ribs right the most famous conference on
neural networks on Friday right but we
will see it right now working uh so I
don't want to explain the details right
about how it works the only important
thing to understand is that we just not
consider text right for the final
prediction and for the final actually
not predictions so generation
But we also incorporate
embeddings coming from graph neural
networks. So I would like to show you
how we can finally chat with the graph
that we created using this G retriever.
Right? So we created this knowledge
graph and now we want to chat with this
graph and let's have a look. Right? The
G retriever has been implemented also in
Python geometric in its last version. So
it's very new. Um here you have a
collection of nodes and the related
description obviously generated with
GPT4 and then you have the collection of
edges. So this graph that you can see
here is the blues graph that you see
here in the slide. So let's try to ask
questions. Explain how permutation
equivariance works in graph neural
networks and discuss its potential
usefulness in antimony laundering
applications and additionally explore
how the concept of equivariance in graph
neural networks relates to the shift
equivariance observed in the internal
layers of convolutional neural networks.
You should be able to answer right this
question here. Let's see what the go
generates.
um it generates actually a big response
right. Uh I would like to show you that
here I initialize my graph attention
network GNN and I pass it it um
basically uh okay here I initialize the
G retriever model and you can see that I
pass the LLM which is the llama 2 the
graph neural network and so on and this
is the generation of the response but
notationary variances blah blah blah I
will give you as an exercise to read it
but then I made it another experiment
right in which I use the traditional
Microsoft graph rag and we can see in
this case that in the model basically we
do not pass any graph neural network
representation of the nodes we just pass
some community detected in the graph and
it produces right this answer that is
very verbose and so on. uh then what I
did I made another experiment asking to
GBT4 to compare the results. So response
A come from G retriever and response B
come from the traditional graph
applications. This is just calling the
APIs of um I didn't share the API keys,
right? So to run it, you have to I
didn't pay for that. But anyway,
regarding the response, right? We we try
to evaluate the response A coming from
the encoding of graph of nodes using
graph neural networks and then B that
didn't use a graph neural networks and
we said that the better response is the
response A so the response in which we
incorporate the representation learned
using graph neural networks I mean it's
not so stable it's something on the edge
but just to let you know that with graph
neural networks we can incorporate in a
more advanced way compared to
traditional approaches something that
came into uh our chapters and I
finished. Thank you very much for your
attention. Uh these are some uh URLs
that are connected to me. We are also
writing a book uh in which you will find
also the discussion of today and I hope
that it would be it has useful and thank
you very much really for your attention
please there is a
Uh I think that yes.
>> Ah yeah sure.
>> Thank you. Yeah. Where do you think the
prelaunch is coming from when using?
Does it have to do with
the service?
>> Yeah, you have to consider that in the
original geo implementation we also pass
the textual information related to the
graph. So basically you have this
correspondence between the textual
representation which is embedded using
the LLM and the graph representation
using the graph neural network. So I
think that this combination could be in
some way fruitful right for uh for
generating good results in terms of
response from the childhood.
Yeah.
because a lot of movies.
Yeah, actually this is done already by
geometric in the sense that in the case
of graph convolutional network we
usually use a cache adjust matrix while
in the other um basically architectures
use an edge list right to save
information for the large graph for the
large graph we have to uh try to be
smart right I recently read a paper from
Spotify in which they introduced the
graph neural networks for the
recommendation systems and in order to
make the graph
less bigger. Let me say they did not map
all the connections between the all the
users right to the podcast or to the
songs but they use a graph that express
the concurrence
um information right so basically they
remove the users but if two
true two podcast for instance was like
were liked by two different users they
creating a coing relationships between
the nodes. So for the large graph I mean
we talked with an Nvidia guy and it
seems that they they are reaching very
very extremely effective results in
teros in terms of performance but right
now you have to be smart right you have
to identify some proxies in order to
reduce the dimension of your graph let's
Uh so first of all thank you for this
talk. Um from your experience suppose
that we're training someone on a on a
given graph and suppose that this graph
is light meaning that it goes through
changes over time. How often do you
think we would need to retrain the model
in order to be fresh with the latest
version of the graph?
>> Uh that's a good questions and obviously
this a question from from the real world
right. uh I have to say that uh
it depends on the depth of the
connections that you include right
because let's imagine that you have
already trained graph if you add a new
node in this graph you can perform the
forward propagation so this new node
will receive uh the features trained
from the stable version of the graph. So
in some way we are able to identify a
new representation without training the
graph from scratch. But if you start to
add nodes in a deeper way right so
create a lot of layer of connections
I mean this can be a problem right so
you have to understand how you would add
the new information. If it is just some
nodes with one hope distance then you
can use the inference in order to
propagate the features the train
features to this node. But otherwise is
if the connections becomes deep and
deep. So you add ideally multiple layers
of for transferring the features this
could be start to be a problem right
sense.
>> Yeah. Actually
I have a question and thank you for the
presentation and my question is about
transfer learning. Have you tried um
learning using GNN or whatever
architecture you have tried to learn
something on a graph and then testing
the data set and then test it on a
similar but not exactly the same
context and is it working? Is it
scaling? What are the main problems?
Thank you. Thank you for your question.
And
basically the idea of permutation
invariance and equivariance could be I
mean uh could be useful right in this
sense because if another new graph
actually presents the same relational
structure maybe the graph neural network
could be effective. But now there is a a
very interesting research line related
to conditional model of knowledge graphs
right uh in which knowledge graphs we
means graphs that have a lot of label to
the nodes and a lot of label to the
edges and in that case the research is
open right because uh there are not
still knowledge graph embedding
techniques that are applicable to
different graphs right that represent
different objects there are some
interesting research or from I don't
know if you ever heard his name Michael
Gin that now that worked at Nvidia now
worked at Google that collaborate to de
development of a model called ultra
which is actually it's a model that
tried to be a foundational model in the
context of graphs. So you can have a
look at these research papers in order
to have a better idea.
Yeah.
How do you
the the uh confidence intervals that you
showed earlier can those be surface
through and those actually used
responses? I've seen in a lot of these
cases especially simplified versions
where it's just chat with your data. It
just makes stuff up and you wouldn't
mind if it said I'm making something up
probably first% confidence.
Yeah, that's a an interesting question
and actually a complex question in the
sense that I do not have the answer to
these questions. I can just say that uh
if we are able to incorporate in the
model representation of different
natures right including for instance the
graph neural network one we can gave the
chance to the model to have a I mean
it's
quite high level topic right but a novel
perspective about your data right and
hopefully this novel perspective could
be in some way effective for u proving
providing more accurate results. But
this is just an hypothesis, right? Just
uh speculation I would say.
Okay, if there are no more questions, uh
thank you again for your attention. I
hope that it it has been useful. You
will find all the resources in term of
slides or code in my the profile of the
connected London website and I will
still I will be around right for the
next days until Friday. So if you want
to have a chat with me free to stop me
come and we can chat and talk. Thank you
very much again for your attention.